sujet exceptionnel on va recevoir une
personne qui a découvert Kev Adams Zaz
elle a été l'origine de nombreuses
carrières elle est dans le casting petit
Magnéto et on en parle juste après
[Musique]
avant de se retrouver sur scène sur
notre télévision ou sur nos écrans de
cinéma nos stars préférés ont presque
toutes passées une étape clé le fameux
casting
je fais un mètre 65 j'ai jamais fait de
cinéma et ça m'intéresserait d'en faire
cette épreuve redoutable mais
indispensable sous les dates de Franco
directrice de casting la connaît bien
depuis des années elle déniche les
futures stars de demain on recherche la
doublure de Kev Adams et la doublure de
Gad Elmaleh mais ces derniers temps
celle qui a découvert les Labé Kev Adams
ou encore Zaz raconte avoir vu son
métier évolué et constate aujourd'hui
quelques dérives qu'elle compte bien
dénoncer sur notre plateau alors entre
coulisses de casting et anecdote de
célébrités les incroyables confidences
de l'une des plus grandes délicieuses de
stars ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
on est en train de se dire qu'on est en
train de discuter avec Sacha et de se
dire que vous aviez un visage incroyable
oh là là merci j'ai bien fait de venir
ça va pas s'arrêter alors qu'est-ce qui
vous a attiré dans le lieu du casting
alors ça fait rêver beaucoup de gens
j'ai revu un élément un très bon doc sur
le mycanal sur les sortes du casting de
la boum il y avait toute l'histoire
qu'on met dans trouver etc Sophie
Marceau c'est passionnant qu'est-ce qui
vous a intéressé dans le dans le casting
qu'est-ce qui m'a intéressé dans le
casting alors moi dans le dénicher des
talents voilà moi j'étais pas du tout
destinée au milieu du casting et je suis
issue de l'immigration sud-américaine et
j'ai grandi à Ivry-sur-Seine avec ma
maman et à 13 ans ma mère m'a inscrit à
un cours de théâtre et
j'ai fréquenté Benoît Magimel Elodie
boucher j'ai passé mon premier casting
avec par exemple j'ai passé le casting
de remonter et j'ai découvert un univers
un réseau à l'époque il y a plus de 30
ans et à l'époque c'est un réseau très
fermé j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
Claudie de jouer avec Patrick Bruel dans
profil bas compagnie compagnie mais
c'est un réseau très très fermé
les grands directeurs de casting voilà
ça c'est le métier il y avait quatre
cinq personnes qui détenaient tous les
films qui se font voilà internet
n'existait pas où il y avait trois
quatre directeurs de casting il fallait
être dans le réseau et là on avait la
chance de pouvoir participer et on a eu
l'idée avec mon mari en 1992 de créer un
magazine qui s'appelle casting que
certains connaissent je crois et dans ce
magazine on donnait toutes les infos
pour se lancer dans une carrière
artistique c'est-à-dire toutes les
annonces de casting Leila Bekhti elle en
parle c'est comme ça qu'elle a trouvé
son premier casting et il y a 17 ans on
a eu l'idée de créer un site internet
qui donne l'opportunité à tout le monde
de se lancer dans l'univers des castings
c'est-à-dire un rêve
possible devient réalisable grâce à
internet et on est en rapport on a
découvert beaucoup de personnes
découvert
je serai jamais chanteur j'ai 50000
euros je vais produire une artiste
organisme un casting on avait j'ai 50000
euros je sais pas qui je vais choisir
mais je veux trouver quelqu'un je veux
trouver quelqu'un c'est déjà une bonne
démarche
et on a organisé un casting qu'on a fait
au Salon du Louvre il y a plusieurs
années et parmi les six personnes que
j'ai fait venir on l'a découvert Zaz et
après vous connaissez l'histoire en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est aujourd'hui
il y a une démocratisation du casting
c'est plus comme avant où il fallait
vraiment appartenir au réseau être bien
né on a on a accès à rode parado par
exemple qui a eu le César c'est on l'a
rencontré comme ça grâce à un casting
avec
pharaon on l'a mis il n'était pas du
tout prédestiné à ça il vient pas du
tout de cet univers on a on a accès à
des annonces de casting pour les gens au
fin fond de la Creuse par exemple je
vais te pour expliquer c'est une
plateforme en fait maintenant et les ma
tension les professionnels du métier qui
se tournent vers vous et on cherche tel
profil tel âge etc et en fait vous vous
diffusez là vous diffusez la danse et
les choses qui ont changé aussi c'est
qu'il y a de plus en plus de production
aujourd'hui Netflix qui a changé
beaucoup de choses et de quoi la
téléréalité et les réseaux sociaux aussi
la téléréalité c'est autre chose
d'accord être un artiste et avoir du
talent être un artiste c'est travailler
un texte
[Rires]
moi je me considère tout à fait comme un
artiste tout en étant sorti de
téléréalité ça c'est mon après c'est
comme mon avis moi ça dépend de ce qu'on
fait après voilà les les
je pense que l'intégralité c'est des
choses et on peut y avoir des talents
aussi qui sortent là et qui peuvent
réussir très très bien comme Kev Adams
ou comme ça ou comme ça c'est plus
difficile que la téléréalité c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
Nabilla elle peut faire quelques
interventions dans une série la bonne
téléréalité attention les années 2000
tout ça voilà et encore on en parle de
story par exemple le story Star Academy
la référence voilà ceux qui sont devenus
des légendes tout à fait
mettre un artiste c'est avoir une
passion et il y a des étapes à suivre il
y a des outils si on veut être comédien
déjà il faut travailler il faut avoir un
CV une bande démo et se faire connaître
auprès des directeurs de casting et
surtout ne pas attendre c'est à dire
Kev Adams c'est alors Kev Adams c'est
une histoire c'est les frères Smadja qui
ont ouvert une pizzeria et qui m'ont dit
comment je peux faire connaître ma
mon ma pizzeria j'ai dit viens on fait
Jamel Debbouze venez d'ouvrir son
Comédie Club et je dis tiens et si on
faisait une scène d'humoriste et on a
balancé des annonces de casting et keV
était inscrits et il s'est présenté et
on a fait venir Claude Fournier et
l'histoire voilà mais Kev Adams c'est
typiquement
le mec qui ne pouvait pas faire autre
chose que de jouer sur scène et c'est
une passion est-ce qu'on repère tout de
suite que quelqu'un va à quelque chose
en plus est-ce que c'est voilà est-ce
que
quand on a ce don là on y va lui Kev
Adams c'est sûr dans 5 ans il va il vaut
scène disait le talent c'est d'en
découvrir aux autres il faut avoir du
flair et je pense effectivement que
quand tu as le petit truc ça se voit
tout de suite pourquoi vous avez pas
signé tous ces artistes du coup vous
avez pu les prendre comme moi je ne suis
pas agent
alors c'est ce qu'on me dit souvent mais
c'était par rapport à l'argent je veux
dire c'est intéressant quoi c'est non
mais quand on est agent
et je et je je les accompagne je les
coache je suis coach également et je les
mets en relation et demain j'organise
une Master Class pour les enfants avec
un agent qui s'appelle Gérald Benaim qui
est à Jean pour enfants je les
accompagne mais je ne suis pas agent
découvert comme comme personnalité
Ayem par exemple elle vient de chez
Casting.fr qu'on embrasse j'en ai
beaucoup je travaille beaucoup avec
Bruno berbères
vous parlez de télé-réalité Amir par
exemple Amir c'est un homme exceptionnel
qui est de dentiste est devenu chanteur
et de chanteurs il est devenu comédien
sur scène dans sélectionner avec Steve
Suisse donc en fait toute Internet vous
donne accès aux réseaux à la
démocratisation du casting quand il y a
30 ans il fallait vraiment être dans ce
petit réseau parisien aujourd'hui on a
accès à tout ça dès lors qu'on travaille
un talent de chanteurs d'acteurs je sais
pas aujourd'hui le casting c'est quelque
chose qui est grand les choses possibles
plus facilement qu'avant on a accès aux
annonces de casting très facilement
actuellement et le milieu a changé si on
veut de chanteur avant
aujourd'hui pour être chanteur il faut
proposer il faut créer sa page Youtube
chanter avoir un copain jouer et puis
proposer de la musique et se faire
repérer alors qu'avant les maisons de
disques misez sur vous donc encore une
fois ça vous permet pas se mentir
aujourd'hui ce que vous ça n'existe pas
l'album a un million d'euros etc c'est
terminé ça donc c'est vous qui devez
proposer c'est ce que je dis tout le
temps déjà il y a une différence entre
percer et en vivre le but du jeu pour un
artiste c'est pouvoir en vivre je vous
garantis pas que vous allez devenir Jean
Dujardin ou Marion Cotillard parce
qu'effectivement les places sont peu
enfin il y a pas on va prendre une
comédien je vous dis il y a deux stars
10 qui gagne très bien leur vie 30 30 30
30 30 qui survivent et 50 qui crève de
faim
je viens d'une famille de comédien je
sais de quoi je parle
plus être un comédien
vous avez une question
je me demandais comment vous gagnez
votre vie du coup et parce que vous ne
produisez pas on a alors on fait des du
coaching on fait des paniers les
attentats et mon site est un site payant
aussi d'accord on a selon des choses on
a accès aux annonces quand c'est payant
oui
Béatrice comédienne comédienne
franco-américaine j'ai suivi l'évolution
et le métier a complètement changé avec
les réseaux sociaux même la façon de
prouver de très condensateurs vous avez
pu vous adapter à ça parce que
maintenant il suffit d'aller sur
Instagram ou sur Tik Tok et de voir des
talents donc comment vous vous avez
trouvé votre place parmi lui a
énormément changé à mon époque je parle
comme une vieille mais à mon époque les
directeurs de casting allaient dans les
salles de théâtre on allait on faisait
du casting sauvage aujourd'hui
malheureusement justement souvent les
directeurs de casting demandent ce qu'on
appelle des self-stape je parle pas de
sextape je parle de self tape
le sel c'est à dire que on vous allez
postuler à l'annonce et on va vous dire
ok envoie-moi une vidéo c'est très
compliqué pour un comédien de jouer et
c'est ingrat en Angleterre par exemple
on est obligé de vous répondre et du
coup de vous donner des conseils il est
vrai que le milieu est de plus en plus
compliqué mais moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est
oser ayez l'audace si vous voulez être
comédien qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vous
prenez des cours de théâtre
vous rentrez dans une troupe faites un
CV votre bande démo vous trouvez au
travers mon site ou autre part si vous
voulez le fichier des directeurs de
castings de casting et grâce au contrat
que vous allez avoir vous allez
vous-même allez voir l'agent parce que
les agents ne défendent plus les
comédiens sauf si vous êtes Monica
Bellucci le meilleur
j'aimerais qu'on parle de un peu votre
combat et les dérives sur les castings
pour les enfants alors ça c'est un peu
pour ça que vous êtes là aussi ce soir
alors les casting pour enfants faut
savoir que c'est quand même en France
c'est très réglement réglementé il y a
des heures de travail on peut pas
dépasser un certain nombre d'heures
l'argent il y a des agréments de la DASS
tout le monde peut pas faire du casting
d'enfant il faut être agrémenté donc
tout ça c'est sur les barrières etc et
maintenant l'argent est bloqué jusqu'à
ses 18 ans 10% attribué je crois pour
l'entretien voilà jean et une partie
pour les parents pour l'entretien de
l'enfant pour les parents d'accord mais
pourquoi vous parlez de poser des
questions pour les enfants
alors en fait j'ai sur mon site j'ai 1,5
millions de membres c'est pas que des
abonnés inscrits payants je serai riche
mais j'ai vu un boom c'est plein
d'enfants alors déjà quand on est enfant
on parle pas de carrière on parle
d'envie de s'amuser la première chose
que c'est pas plutôt l'envie des parents
déjà alors
moi j'ai découvert de nombreuses enfants
je pense à Eliott lebro qui a joué dans
énormément de films vous le connaissez
un épisode de section de recherche alors
je suis la marraine d'Elliot lebro
pourquoi
ce gamin sa maman l'a inscrit quand il
était tout petit il avait 5 ans sur
casting.fr et sa mère Christine on
t'embrasse et les annoncer les annoncer
les annoncer les annonces et les autres
figurants sur un film je ne sais plus
quel film le premier rôle oublie son
texte il s'énerve et dit [__] mais
personne ne connaît ce texte
Elliott lebrueux 5 ans il dit oui moi ce
gamin avait l'envie et le talent et
aujourd'hui il fait une très belle
carrière à l'âge de 20 ans quels sont
les dérives ce sont les parents qui
poussent et qui poussent et qui poussent
il y en a pas énormément de dérives à
part vous souveniez
alors en France c'est très réglementé et
puis nous avons de très très belles
histoires Vanessa Paradis Benoît Magimel
Charlotte Gainsbourg on a de très très
belles carrières
cette fille a un talent fou la fille la
petite fille de Claude Zidi la fille
mais elle s'est battue elle est les
dérives les dérives c'est qu'il y a trop
de casting
par exemple des castings sur Internet
les enfants obligatoirement passer par
les agents il y a un agent avec qui je
travaille qui s'appelle Gérald benahim
de l'agence à toi de jouer il vient de
placer dans le prochain film de j'ai
oublié comment il s'appelle le
réalisateur de moto
le 7 juin ça sort au cinéma le gamin a
12 ans 12 ans
moi je vois que les gens qui nous
regardent qui ont peut-être envie que
leurs enfants tentent leur chance c'est
quoi les pièges qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
pas faire des dangers
les dangers c'est de pousser des enfants
à faire des castings alors qu'ils ont
pas envie
être passé des castings
lors de la
tout le long de la séance d'essai je
dois assister à tout ça est-ce que je
peux le demander est-ce que je peux
l'obliger c'est l'obliger non déjà il
faut jamais en
a ouvert une école l'école Royon avec
tous les enfants il y a 6 enfants par
soir ah mais c'est ça qui peut dire sur
les dates c'est dire aussi que aux
parents qui veulent par exemple
peut-être essayer que leurs enfants
parce que leurs enfants ont du talent et
l'envie admettons qu'il y a beaucoup de
faux casting qui a beaucoup de pièges
aussi et que les parents si c'est un
casting normal on le droit d'assister au
casting c'est à dire que si on dit au
parlementaire au casting a le droit
d'assister au tournage je conseille à
tout le monde de prendre un agent il est
fondamental d'avoir un agent et surtout
il faut éviter de pousser les enfants il
y en a trop il y a le monde adulte quand
même il faut le dire aux gens et c'est
un monde d'adultes moi je et
le connaissant bien à moins qu'un enfant
est vraiment une vocation et une passion
vraiment innée je suis pas du tout pour
mettre les enfants dans dans
moitié si jeune c'est vraiment un métier
d'adulte et c'est un monde d'adulte
pour résumer donc
voyez l'écoute de votre enfant ça c'est
la base de tout casting qui va faire on
s'y rend on y va on le laisse pas y
aller seul bien évidemment on assiste à
toute la séance avec lui et si ça se
passe bien dans la foulée on prend un
agent alors l'agent je vous explique en
gros c'est quelqu'un qui va négocier
votre cachet et il est censé le faire au
mieux de vos intérêts et vous protéger
et vous protéger pour surtout ce qui est
voilà et surtout faut dire aux enfants
que s'il rate le casting c'est pas grave
parce qu'elle est
tellement vous pouvez donc c'est
difficile
s'informer si vous voulez faire de la
pub il existe des agences de pub comme
bout de chou si vous voulez faire de la
comédie musicale il existe des écoles
les directeurs de casting en fait il y a
en fait il y a des voilà c'est réglement
c'est très structuré n'allez pas
n'importe où et prenez des agences ou
des agents qui sont référencés merci
beaucoup c'est le DAB merci beaucoup